pour bien des journées
toi
antoyé to fall
fall
les enfants de toutes les femmes battues
chaque année en france sont oubliés
pendant longtemps personne ne s'est posé
de questions sur ce qu'ils ressentaient
face à cette violence
[Musique]
la jurisprudence et les textes ne
reconnaissent pas le fait que les
enfants soient des victimes même mais on
va dire directe de ces hommes là
lorsque une femme est traité de tous les
noms et tiré par les cheveux et tenté
d'assassiner devant son enfant
l'enfant va assister à une scène
facetime mortifère
c'est un enfant qui va voir en face la
mort ou la peur de la mort de sa propre
mère
en silence dans le secret
ces enfants perdent leur innocence
et lorsqu'ils grandissent parce qu'elles
sont toujours profonde
[Musique]
est-ce que tu sembles pas une part de
vivre sans toi
c'est pourquoi tout simplement
parce apple
je toujours dans la mort je suis
toujours dans la violence je suis
toujours dans
toujours dans ce contexte haulotte
est un travail sur toi
tout seul c'est peut-être pas terrible
peut-être que le jour où j'aurai un truc
plus un mot plus haut que l'autre nous
dire ah bah c'est normal doit pas été
chez le psy et quand je vais chez le psy
j'ai fait un peu de psycho début quand
je vais la bo je sais qu'il ya un truc
qui va pas donc je le sors pas du cirque
en fait et
je parle m6
qui a d'autres problèmes et ou machin et
non c'est parce qu'il me faut quoi
[Musique]
luna est la petite soeur de kenny
il ya trois ans
l'insouciance dans laquelle elles
grandissent s est effondrée
te fais des bisous moment
elle
ne t'aime pas je m'en voisine quand tu
peux le thème
sa mère bernadette avait 42 ans
lorsqu'elle est morte tuée par son mari
elle a vécu 24 ans avec le père de ses
enfants
une vie pleine de faux semblants
voilà le petit nid d'amour
[Musique]
votre maison quinze ans auparavant son
mari bâti de ses propres mains la maison
familiale
[Musique]
arrêtons de wons
jouer
bernadette la mer à 27 ans elle vient de
mettre l'ona au monde
oui
mais il y avait la grande soeur de l'ona
[Musique]
kenny et de fils aîné la mère au foyer
s'occupe des enfants
[Applaudissements]
le père et pompiers il gagne bien sa vie
[Musique]
c'était la foi munich l on était
vachement proche on s'entendait bien on
a toujours été chouchouté par papa maman
toujours eu tout ce qu'on voulait ouais
c'était des beaux jours le bouchon il
n'y avait pas de routine en fait tous
les jours il se passait quelque chose de
différent et c'est ça que j'aimais chez
mes parents étaient des bons moments
ensemble et c'était c'était cool
aujourd'hui kenny à 25 ans
si on est bon chemin
[Musique]
il n'est pas revenu ici depuis deux ans
entre ses murs sa vie de famille a fini
en tragédie
plus personne ne vit là
cette maison attend d'être vendus
kevin lui l'herbe l'une de ses soeurs
melia et luna ont 24 et 18 ans elle non
plus n'était jamais revenu
on mettait les transats là on mettait
étrangers cela après maman elle a dit on
va les métaux intéresse
bronze et là c'était bien
fut bizarre comme on le sent qu'il ya
plus de lui en fête fut bien
j'ai toile d'araignée qui a partout
il fait très froid dans la maison
le temps est comme suspendu
et regain pour le moment ça va c'était
mystique
[Musique]
seule la grand mère maternelle a senti
le danger rôde et autour de sa fille
omer chéri
bernadette sa fille était une enfant
très sage
elle travaille dans un salon de coiffure
lorsqu'elle rencontre son premier amour
le seul
je vais allez y et de pas se mettre avec
lui parce que c'était pas sa première
femme et il en est à sa 4e c'était
quelqu'un de tête de deuil puis je vous
dis ces essais ont dit l'amour rend
aveugle
quand
dans l'un des corps
[Musique]
la percée
avant les premières années bernadette
souris sans cesse
elle fonde sa famille
la dent
son mari films chaque moment heureux
[Musique]
fier de l'image parfaite il foyer qui
l'a créé
[Musique]
il est adjoint au maire du village
pompiers professionnels il est même
décoré par xavier bertrand alors
ministre et maire de la ville de saint
quentin
[Musique]
j'avais beaucoup de respect pour lui
c'était papa on est en sécurité un peu
plus
mon père c'était tout pour moi c'était
j'étais c'était mon modèle je voulais
toujours prendre exemple sur sur lui et
c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours été j'ai
plus été dans le garage avec mon père
que à la cuisine avec maman grand
bonhomme charismatique et où sa grosse
gueule
lui arrivait toujours à voir ce qu'il
voulait
près des gens tout ce je voyais que les
gens ils écoutaient beaucoup donc
donc ouais ça force le respect et puis
c'est vrai j'en avais peur
et ses pairs
on savait qu'ils avaient du caractère et
puis que ça pouvait partir ça pour les
parties règlent quoi
c'était sur ses traits s'il était comme
ça où on va on savait que non et puis
voici l'arrivée un peu détendu bon bah
oui ça l'est ils ce sont des enfants qui
qui d'abord sont en état de
d'hypervigilance je sais qu'à partir de
thé leur papa va pouvoir rentrer si papa
rentre il ne faut pas faire du bruit
s'il ne faut pas faire du bruit je ne
vais pas écouter la télé donc je vais
rester dans ma chambre à ne rien faire
et puis on va s'adapter à lui parce que
parfois il est entré il est gentil mais
parfois il rentre il et des bas dans un
état de rage et donc on va exister le
moins possible est rentré dans sa
coquille c'est à dire ne rien répondre
ne rien dire dire ouï dire qu'il a
toujours raison c'est à dire que
l'enfant va de moins en moins à exister
ouais c'était
on était réglé cool je suis à chaque peu
trop dire autrement et c'était réglé
c'était on était
à sa disposition ça
comme il voulait
si on répondait on pouvait sans point de
vue
j'ai déjà vu mon frère vous voulez vous
voulez sur un ace à 4,5 m mais mettez
des points qu est ce qu elle faisait
notamment
n'était
elle était apeuré 10 et arrêtent peu
près 2 et à amuser pareil plus longtemps
résonné dans l'hotêl arrêt mais pourquoi
ils s'arrêtaient pas c'était ferme ta
gueule taran à dire quoi elle essayé de
les séparer mais il n'y arrivait pas
ouais 100 kg d'art bug qui de fonce
dessus
[Musique]
tu peux pas faire grand chose une petite
femme comme moment on pouvait préférence
sinon les enfants leur père aurait été
violent avec kenny
[Musique]
un seul film de famille laisse entrevoir
la violence de l'homme
[Applaudissements]
le
c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce jour là il joue
mais il aura fallu presque dix ans pour
que les enfants comprennent et analyse
ce qui se jouait dans le couple de leurs
parents
papaye où il avait en sa possession de
maman s'était
dit est un objet elle était soumise en
parle
j'étais poser de questions sur l'année
dans ton père et de mère
ont joué tout était normal moi
[Musique]
dans leur tête la représentation qu'ils
ont de ce qu'être un hameau de ce
qu'être une femme est bien être un homme
sait être supérieur être une femme c'est
être dévalorisé ça ils peuvent la voir
vraiment on a ramassé beaucoup du midi
beaucoup
tous les jours elle avait des post-it
partout pour dire tu fais ceci tu fais
ça tu nettoies derrière le gaz tu es
quand il rentrait le lendemain matin et
regardez cet effet on avait devant nous
un tyran un manipulateur
au début les enfants disent n'avoir
jamais vu leur mère se faire battre
comme ça marchera t bonds avait
acheté un petit tri et se souviennent
d'elle et un dixième des violences ils
se sont construits dans le déni pour
pouvoir continuer à vivre on l'entend
pour les viols mais on doit aussi
l'entendre pour les violences conjugales
en parlant longuement avec eux l'art
mémoire se libère peu à peu
comme j'étais petit et une grosse
bagarre j'avais 6 ans je m'en rappelle
encore beaucoup d'image et ce qui s'est
passé sur il est descendu de la voiture
il a traîné ma mère jusqu'au devant
l'immeuble on est monté jusqu'au 16e
comme ça ils attirent et comment
je saurai pas il a tiré par terre la
traînée par terre
a été vachement l'état binaire jour-là
a eu des ecchymoses et des hématomes
mais ça se voyait quoi beaucoup plus
aéré gens là je rappelle qu'on a
beaucoup pleuré
et puis on est avec mailhiot tous les
deux a regardé ça qu on flippe et
la porter plainte non elle n'a pas voulu
[Musique]
elle essayait toujours comme si tout
allait bien oui volant mais n'importe
comment il fallait parce qu'il était
toujours des regrets
je ne dis pas qu elle parle
elle gardait tout pourrait tous
voulaient pas qu'on s'inquiète ou
je ne sais rien
[Musique]
pendant ces 24 ans de vie commune
combien de violence bernadette elle
subit en secret
elle seule et son mari le savent
mais un mois avant sa mort le soir du 7
janvier 2015
le père ne peut contenir sa rage au
milieu du salon devant ses filles
il a pris l'ordinateur et la balancer
sur moment sur visage de maman et moi
j'étais en haut à ce moment-là et mélia
l'étambot et donc j'ai entendu ça je
suis descendu vite j'ai couru et j'ai vu
maman qui me regardait avec les courts
les yeux grands ouverts et qui misait
n'ai pas peur le loup t'inquiète pas tu
ont fait pas ça va aller ça va aller et
moi je relis je fais normalement ça va
pas allez viens avec moi viens avec moi
et et mélia qui est en train de retenir
papa qui il voulait encore mettre sur la
figure à maman s'il était complètement
fou quoi tu dérailles tu pètes en plan
qu'est ce qui t'arrive les bougies
diamant va-t'en va-t'en moi j'étais en
train de en faire une crise d'angoissé
en train de mordre la main en train de
pleurer comme je sais pas quoi et et
après je suis descendu et may hamm a dit
que maman était parti chez papy délai
déjà vu la peur dans le visage de sa
mère avant non
non
j'étais pas là je te paulo il n'a jamais
fait de mal à ma mère quand j'étais là
[Musique]
depuis ce qui ce qui lui avait fait avec
l'ordinateur elle avait très peur de lui
et elle dormait tout enlèvement corps et
même le fermer la porte à elle fermé la
porte à clé pas de porte de chambre à
clé parce que à l mode multi bacau tu me
disais tout le temps il va me faire du
mal à me faire du mal je le sens je le
sais faire du mal
[Musique]
je crois que c'est avec les limouxins
oui oui
bah avec ce qu'elle me calme me disais
est ce qu elles nous disaient ouais
dans cette famille les enfants ont vécu
une réalité déformée
ils ne se sont rendus compte de rien
les violences dont ils pensent que leur
mère était victime était la plupart du
temps de cacher
mais dans la majorité des cas les
enfants assistent chaque jour à la
brutalité de leur père
la gare du nord une jeune fille de 18
ans veut se perdre parmi les gens
sephora ne veux pas qu'on sache d'où
elle vient
pendant 10 ans sous ses yeux de son père
a frappé sa mère
[Musique]
je le voyais ensuite et maman puis l'a
frappé son mieux sous mes yeux et lui
donner des coups et en fait partout il
poursuit sur son corps
que ça soit visage ventre jambes
s'en foutait il ce jeu n'est pas de la
frapper alors que j'étais j'étais là où
m'émeut mes frères et ça on était là et
il se gênait pas qu'est ce qui fait le
plus peur dans ces zones c'était
entendre les bruits de tan tan maman
crier
mais lui l'entente de l'insulté et juste
après ne plante ans de maman mais
entendent
ces écoutes point où ses coups de pied
sur maman
j'entendais ça et après j'ai eu je
l'entends que j'entendais plus rien et
c'est là que je commence à paniquer en
me disant mais
peut-être qu'elle est morte
qu'est ce qui fait que ça fait très peur
aux enfants c'est qu'ils savent que ça
peut aller vers le drame et quand on
parle de drame c'est à dire vers une
violence maximum c'est à dire la mort
chateaubriand disait qu' on ne pouvait
on ne veut pas voir la mort en face et
là c'est un enfant qui va voir en face
la mort ou la peur de la mort de sa
propre mère
la mère de sephora n'avait que 17 ans
lorsqu'elle l'a mise au monde
[Musique]
sephora est l'aîné des quatre enfants
comment se protéger face à un père
effrayant
aussi loin qu'elle se souvienne son
instinct a toujours été celui de la
survie
elle sourit sur les photos mais la
terreur l'a toujours envahi
où
j'essaie de me cacher et
je faisais tout pour pas entendre les
bruits c'était des cachettes enfants en
dessous du lit ou sous la couette avec
tous les jeux
ont même dans la chambre de maman dans
son armoire je me bouche et les oreilles
ou
où je pleurais où je tremblais
énormément et je protégeais mes frères
et soeurs je prenais avec moi et
j'allais plus loin possible si par
exemple la scène de violence était dans
la cuisine chez je suis monté au
deuxième étage dans la chambre la porte
fermée
et je m'amuse avec eux je parlais
beaucoup pour justement qu'ils entendent
plus ma voix et mes reer que
que l'écrit
mon coeur est bat est tellement fort et
vite que j'ai l'impression qu'il allait
sortir mon corps et
j'entendais mon coeur battre dans mes
tempes ce qui m'a empêché de raisonner
et de penser parce que quand je voyais
les les signes du fait qu'il allait être
méchant c'est à dire c'est point où
c'est le temps qui grince où son regard
il est devenu tellement méchant de
attend juste de grands puisque jean de
me rappeler de sa tête et c'est
tellement horrible
quand je vois que le ces signes la
présence mais en quoi j'ai du coup je me
l'imaginais et ça c'est encore super
présent dans mon esprit
mois il son regard tout c'était son
regard son sa façon d'être de parler
pour moi c'était plus un humain qui
était sous mes yeux
c'était vraiment un animal qui voulait
juste
mangé sa pro à prendre le plaisir et
prenez du plaisir à faire mal
spie main
l'homme bat la mer mais il s'en prend
aussi aux enfants il est de plus en plus
violents
mal à tenir
et jean louis
caniaux
[Musique]
il est 20 heures le 18 juin 2009
j'étais dans la chambre et il a activé
il était tout rouge était en colère et
il avait les poings fermés
et
j'ai rien compris je juge je regardais
devant moi devant devant l'armoire et
j'ai juste tourner la tête et je les ai
vus mais se jeter sur moi
mais vraiment tel un animal et il me
frappait et recevoir un grand coup sûr
sur la tête et c'est ce coup là qui m'a
complètement endormi pendant des heures
mais c'était différent de toutes les
autres fois
parce que les autres fois je je savais
pourquoi ils me frappaient je veux dire
il n'y a pas de raison pour qu'on frappe
quelqu'un mais je savais pourquoi il y
il avait ces gestes-là envers moi que la
non là je ne comprenais pas pourquoi
et je me suis réveillée mais vers minuit
quelque chose comme ça donc des heures
après
j'entendais des cris
et je suis descendu
et
j'ai pas réussi à traverser la porte à
l'aidant dans la cuisine je me suis dit
si j'y vais qu'est ce que je vais voir
je sais pas je me suis dit est-ce qu'il
fallait juste que je fais ce moment
faire ce qui est ce qu a voulu faire je
savais qu'elle voulait juste lui parler
ce que j'avais peur maman n'avaient
jamais le droit à
parler avec lui
du coup je préférais rester avec mes
frères et soeurs
ce qui s'est passé cette nuit là
sa mère ont fait le récit devant la cour
d'assises de douai
parce qu'il est l'illustration de toutes
les violences vécues par les femmes
exceptionnellement son procès a été
filmée
vers 2 heures du matin il s'est levé
pour aller
se faire une cigarette
et quand il est revenu je lui ai dit que
j'avais quelque chose il fallait qu'on
discute
bialo je t'écoute j'écoute jus moi je
voulais voir un avocat
et je demande le divorce
et je lui dis
que je vais porter plainte sur la
violence que je subis n'est que les
enfants subissent aussi
hélas ma sortie
je vais te crever
et après il s'est jeté sur moi
m'a assommé du coup
il m'a donné des claques
d'une forte claque
d'abord vu la main droite
il m'avait tremblay
et dans une gifle ma tête a été sur la
sur la gauche
et de là j'ai vu le couteau et
je lui ai porté secours
on est sortis de la maison et je vois
maman à travers la vie tu mets dans la
voiture de police
et je me suis dit c'est pas normal
c'est pas normal parce que tous savent
pas ce qu'elles auraient juste mis un
met fin à une vie d'une personne mais
c'était même plus une personne si maman
avait pas réussi
à défendre c'était peut-être nous
c'était peut-être elle avec nous qui
allons tous mourir
à l'issue de ce procès retentissant
alexandra l'ange fait acquitter
[Musique]
elle fut même acquitté à la majorité
absolue
[Musique]
à saint quentin
la veille du vendredi 13 février 2015
bernadette comme alexandra l'ange
annonce elle aussi à son mari qu'elle va
demander le divorce
à 9 heures du matin dans le village
calme de benêt les trois enfants
commencent une journée comme tant
d'autres
moi j'étais tout seul dans la maison je
me préparais parce que j'avais ma
dernière heure de conduite pour pouvoir
passer le permis et
c'était la moitié venait me chercher je
travaillais avec
l'entreprise du village qui était au
collège
et je sortais de la cantine
je reçois un appel sur mon portable dont
les réponses des mots certes elles ne
sortent tous cas la vue en résumé qu
elle nous sort tous les du sang partout
il fume une clope ils sont battus moment
les parterres et puis je vais poser des
questions même rythme pour n'est pas
bien me répondait à côté de la plaque
donc là j'ai flippé quand j'ai dit il
faut qu'on entre abonnés chaude par aude
supporter ma soeur anne qui est la
fenêtre en haut à me dire c'est en bas
ça s'est passé au sous sol donc je
descends je cours je vois le scénic qui
était encore en train de tourner moteur
y tournait encore
puis je vois mes parents par terre les
deux partenaires dans plein de son plein
de sang plein de sang
et j'ai compris directement que c'était
fini qu'on vit tous le sens qu'il y
avait je me suis pas dit qu'ils avaient
quelque chose à faire je savais que
c'était fini acte est morte
j'ai eu l'impression que
que j'ai l'impression que le maudit
kenny avant de partir son dernier
souffle peut-être je sais pas où
peut-être que ces mots qui espérait saut
et j'ai cru entendre dans une
respiration qui dit
jeu patients
placés en détention le père a demandé
d'assister aux obsèques
refusé
deux ans plus tard il est condamné à 16
ans de réclusion criminelle pour
assassinats
lorsqu'il est incarcéré luna lui envoie
une lettre elle en a gardé un brouillon
josé papa comment je suis à fait pour
che maman idiot tu l'as tuée parce que
tu l'aimés est ce qu'on tue par amour
est ce qu'on tue sa femme parce qu'on
les aime trop je ne t'aime plus tu m'a
enlevé mon fils et mon rayon de soleil
maintenant je galère je suis triste à en
mourir j'ai tellement de colère
tellement de tristesse je meurs à petit
feu
[Musique]
la réalité endurées par ces enfants
seuls quelques spécialistes s'y sont
intéressés
[Musique]
à force de croiser des enfants de cabot
c'est le juge edward durant a découvert
l'impact d'un véritable tsunami
[Musique]
les violences conjugales sont parmi les
maltraitances les plus graves qui
puissent être infligée à un enfant elle
le coz des traumatismes majeurs des
traumatismes qui sont de l'ordre des
traumatismes
vécus par l'enfant dans les situations
de guerre ou de terrorisme
[Applaudissements]
kenny vit aujourd'hui au bord de la
rocade de saint quentin il se sent
triste tout le temps
il cogite beaucoup sur la tyrannie de
son père
je culpabilise pour ce qui est arrivé
pour réparer tout donc
c'est moi le grand frère
j'aurais peut-être dû
protéger tout le monde et puis j'ai pas
réussi coûts
va peut-être pu protéger tout le monde
depuis les débuts
n'ont pu je sais pas où déclenchant une
alerte
en disant que sa voix pas et puis
puis parler des problèmes plutôt que
deux
plutôt que de laisser de côté et puis
faire comme s'il y avait rien
peut-être que si j'avais cassé mémoire
et briser la glace avant
il y aurait pas eu tous ces problèmes
ils ont souvent envie de protéger le
parent qui est victime est au demeurant
ils ne veulent pas non plus
jugé embastillé dénigrer le parent qui
est l'homme violent penser l'homme
violent il faudrait qu'il se fasse
soigner
il faudrait qu'ils comprennent et donc
c'est l'enfant qui a 8 ans 10 ans qui va
dire à son parent de se faire soigner on
est dans ce système d'inversion qui peut
paraître surréaliste
j'avais l'impression de 2
peut-être le père de mon père
j'avais l'impression de gérer ces
gamineries
j'avais un enfant go
les enfants n'ont pas le choix la
violence conjugale les oblige à grandir
plus vite
[Musique]
maman après une scène de violence où
elles n'étant s est fait battre
quelqu'un qu'elle avait du sens et qui
elle sans fermer à clé dans la salle de
bain et qu'elle voulait pas que je sois
là et que moi j'étais à la porte à
l'extérieur par terre à lui tire mais
maman laisse pas rentrer s'il te plait
je veux être avec toi qu'elle me disait
non alors parce que juste avant j'avais
j'avais pas été présente pour l'aider je
culpabilise et je me suis dit mais elle
m'en veut elle m'en veut parce que j'ai
pas été là pour l'est pour l'aider pour
la défendre du coup a fait plus de moi
tu te sentais impuissante totalement
qui dois je protégeais
si j'emmène mes petits frères et soeurs
dans la chambre pour qu'ils ne soient
pas devant la scène de violence
conjugale je les protège mais je ne
protège pas à ma mère
si je m'interposer entre mon père et ma
mère pour que mon père ne puisse pas
exercer des violences contre ma mère je
protège ma mère mais je ne me protège
pas
si j'appelle la police
je protège ma mère et je protège mes
frères et soeurs et moi même mais
peut-être que je mets mon père en danger
peut-être qu'il va aller en prison
l'enfant est dans un conflit de
protection et doit résoudre ce conflit
dans un temps très court et seul
pendant dix ans et fort a été verrouillé
par son père il la menace si elle parle
elle sera placée est séparé de sa mère
[Musique]
la seule solution serait de s'enfuir
mais elle c'est sa mère écartelé et sous
l'emprise de sans peur
je comprenais qu'elle avait peur de
partir de s'enfuir je comprenais qu'elle
n'avait pas les moyens de de pouvoir
prendre justement un hôtel par ci par là
chaque nuit de jeux comprennent aussi le
fait qu'elle n'avait pas de voiture et
que comme personne vous voulez l'aider à
porter comment à pied on ne pouvait pas
le faire mais tout ça je comprenais mais
moi j'avais envie de voir la volonté
de quelqu'un qu'elle ait envie de partir
avec nous je lui ai répété sans cesse
vian par cette nuit on prépare les sacs
si tu veux tu t'occupes de lui en bas et
moi je prépare les sacs et elle amusée
non je pas de priver ton père après tout
c'est ton père est quand même là c'est
une femme victime de violences
conjugales ne quitte pas son mari
violent
on lui dit mais pourquoi ne part pas
vous devez partir vous devez protéger
vos enfants et quand elle quitte son
mari violent on lui dit mais pourquoi
vous partez vous devez garantir que vous
allez rester en lien avec le père pour
maintenir le lien parent enfant la
société dans une injonction paradoxale
qui souvent confine à la stratégie de
l'agresseur et ses hommes cherchent à
tuer ces femmes parce que il ne
n'admettent pas qu'est leur échappe
c'était leur chose leur objet leur
thérapeute leur constitution leur
constituante et il est impossible
qu'elle puisse se séparer d'eux
donc si elle se sépare d'eux eh bien
elle devra mourir parfois lui avec et
parfois les enfants avec
ainsi une fois sur trois lorsqu'elles
veulent partir les femmes meurent
les premiers touchés sont évidemment les
enfants
pendant de longs mois luna s'est terrée
dans le mutisme
melia était très proche de son père
la trahison fit absolue
mon père d'avant me manque et mon père
devant je voulais me mais en ont ils une
autre personne et c'est ce qu'il a fait
je ne peux pas lui pardonner c'est
terminé c'est le considéra plus quand
mon père
pour moi il a il nous a aidé à torturer
aussi de toute façon on ne peut pas il
n'y a pas d'autre
il n'ya pas d'autre mot là dessus nous
ça nous a tués aussi de toute façon et
les mots de ses enfants la société les
entend rarement
en france le lien biologique est encore
inscrit dans les mentalités
et la plupart des juges maintiennent la
force de l'autorité paternelle
vous avez par exemple des pères qui sont
incarcérés parce qu'ils ont tué la mère
des enfants et qui conserve l'autorité
parentale que c'est eux qui ont la
prérogative d'autoriser ou d'interdire
que l'enfant soit soigné par un
pédopsychiatre ou un psychologue
et que on va imposer à l'enfant le
maintien des liens en prison
[Musique]
à parme il ya aucun des enfants n'a
rendu visite à son père en prison
aujourd'hui ils se sentent orphelins et
doivent se reconstruire
ils vivent chacun de leur côté avec les
350 euros par mois köhler perverse à la
demande de la justice
meli à vie dans un foyer pour jeunes
travailleurs et pour l'instant elle ne
travaille pas
luna avait 15 ans au moment des faits
elle a vécu deux ans chez sa grand mère
depuis elle n'a pas de maison elle
[Musique]
elle dort chez médias ou chez son petit
ami
quand on me dit oui à tout le monde pour
toi tout le monde est là pour toi je
veux y mêlant à l'enterrement de maman
et bébé vraiment toutes mes amis du
collège qu'ils étaient là mes meilleurs
amis et tous et quand je vois leur
d'aujourd'hui plus personne
quand je mets une photo de maman sur
internet un truc comme ça va l'être tout
le monde revient lendemain a plus
personne c'est un truc de ouf henry du
puch rivier de la pitié et oui les gens
qui est nouveau c'est vraiment elle te
pèse aujourd'hui cette solitude ouais
bah ouais de ouf
[Musique]
il ya un moment dans ma ville l'année
dernière j'y arrivais plus je n'arrivais
plus à à supporter ce passé
c'était trop douloureux pour moi et
et je voulais juste que ça stoppe
j'avais tout le temps sa tête temps dans
ma tête je dormais plus parce que quand
tu fermer les yeux et j'avais
l'impression qu'il était là tout le
temps
et j'ai vu quand j'ai juste pris ses
médicaments c'était juste pour ne plus
penser juste stopper tout ça et ne plus
penser à lui
je me demande pourquoi est-ce que la
vieille beaucoup de vécu
un c'est compliqué c'est compliqué
franchement c'est les nuits je passe des
nuits de folie donc
c'est des cauchemars c
c'est toujours mon père qui fait du mal
à ma mère ma mère qui pleure dans mes
bras comme si en fait ce n'était pas un
cauchemar mais que c'était épique
viens et puis on parle en fait comme si
elles veulent rôle essentiel pour me
parler et
et j'ai luna qui tourne autour de nous
nous on pleure et on se cache pour pas
clown au nouveau on se tourne chevaux
clowns elle tourne on le voit on se
cache et j'ai mon père car il voit
l'affairé et qui fait du mal à ma mère
toujours de toujours une arme
toujours et moi je peux rien faire je
peux jamais rien faire c'est un enfant
victime de violences conjugales qui m'a
fait comprendre ce que sont les rues
reviviscence un petit garçon qui avait
cinq ou sept ans et il me dit je fais
des cauchemars
je fais des cauchemars même quand je
dors pas
il est à l'école il est en train de
faire des lignes d'écriture il est en
train d'apprendre une leçon ou de jouer
avec ses camarades de classe et tout
d'un coup la scène de violence conjugale
ressurgit à l'état brut laissons les
cris
les odeurs les couleurs les visages la
scène redevient actuelle dans sa mémoire
traumatique
même si j'avais envie d'apprendre de
fermer de voir dell à l'école
je pouvais jamais être attentifs en
classe j'arrêtais pas de penser à la
maison et je me disais maman je sais
qu'elle à la maison lui aussi moi je
suis ici il ya personne d'autre à la
maison peut-être qu'en fait il qu en
train de la frapper toute la journée
je me souviens pour les tables de
multiplication j arrivais pas et
cm1 et
et ont refusé tout le temps contrôler je
me souviens que le professeur il avait
demandé
un certain nombre d'élèves mais j'étais
dans ce pack est là et sauf que c'était
des élèves qui travaillaient pas alors
que moi je voulais réussir je voulais
travailler mais j'y arrivais pas
depuis peu les neurosciences démontre
comment la peur qui investit tout
l'espace mental des enfants bouleverse
leur cerveau on comprend mieux les
mécanismes à la fois parce qu on les
étudie mieux qu on observe mieux les
femmes victimes les enfants victimes
mais aussi parce que l'imagerie médicale
nous aident à penser que ça a des
conséquences sur le cerveau on peut
observer que
dans le cerveau le lieu de la mémoire
qui est donc l'hippocampe peut être plus
réduit donc ça donne l'idée si vous
voulez que ça a des conséquences
neurophysiologiques importante tu as des
problèmes de mémoire oui
et même morale est extrêmement
défaillante
même quand je fais tout pour me souvenir
d'un petit truc je mets du temps où j'ai
vraiment pas m'en souvenir
perte de mémoire échec scolaire envies
suicidaires
ces enfants porte de nombreuses
séquelles
certaines peuvent mettre les autres en
danger
70% des mineurs délinquants que voit le
juge dans son bureau sont des enfants de
femmes battues
[Musique]
la violence à l'égard des autres et
cruauté contre les animaux la violence
contre sa petite amie voir contre sa
mère par imitation au père violent
[Applaudissements]
je
la violence dont il a hérité kanye ne
veut pas l'entendre raisonner en lui
[Musique]
comment le fondateur personnes bientôt
plaît ouais moi je fais tout moment par
lui ressembler mais je sais que dire
semble donc
je séchais ressemble je sais que j'ai
les mêmes gènes que lui donc
forcément
il ya un moment où je pourrai pu voler
au niveau physique mon nom
m'avoue
bataille
toutes ces autres changera paumé qu'on a
porté la main sur un bas justement non
c'est un truc que maintenant je supporte
plus c'est un mec qui vont
wiki m yoland quoi
fuir le mal à tout prix
se délester de la fatalité transmises
par ses propres parents
jacqueline nous confie qu'elle portait
un secret
[Musique]
même vous êtes enfants de femmes battues
mais avec quoi il faut pas perdre pas au
parfois quartier zone et des fers à
repasser ce que dans le temps c'était
différent insiste sur le feu prenez un
fer à repasser une balle en six ans
armons nous on a vu tout sur lui
vous avez des fruits oui j'avais un
frère une soeur
ben mon frère s'est suicidé
alors moi j'ai dit voyez
j'ai toujours peur de l'homme
est ce que vous l'avez transmise et
votre fille
d'avis
et je lui disais toujours
ai dit tu sais maman elle connaît les
hommes ils sont méchants
le mari de bernadette at il senti dès le
début cette peur transmise par la
grand-mère
au point de choisir sa proie pour
libérer son appétit d'emprise
être enfant de femmes battues change
forcément tous les rapports amoureux
je suis dégoûté des hommes
quand il ya un homme qui est que je vois
juste passé dans la bossa ça m'écoeure
complètement je pense que là c'est une
séquelle parce que s est mis à rien
demander aux plus pauvres mais là rien
demandé et et dans ma tête j'ai peur de
lui parce que il a un truc qui me fait
penser à mon géniteur ou même par
exemple juste l'odeur d'un homme me
t'écoute
déjà tombe amoureuse
d'un garçon
n'ont peut-être un jour
mais
non
[Musique]
pendant de longues années sephora fut
entourée par des psys et des éducateurs
elle est c'est enfin aujourd'hui de
découvrir ce cas une vie normale
à
marianne fatale les enfants peuvent tout
à fait reprendre un développement
ordinaire à condition que d'un côté et
la séparation avec l'agresseur se fasse
c'est à dire que les enfants vivent avec
leur mère dans un lieu de sécurité
premiers éléments et deuxièmement qu'ils
aient des soins adaptés qui donne du
sens à ce qu'ils ont vécu ils vont
pouvoir reprendre un développement
normal
reconnecter leurs émotions se
reconnecter justement à la mémoire et
reprendre un vieux reprendre une vie
ordinaire
comment grandir devenir un adulte
bienveillant lorsque l'on porte ces
violences en soi
pendant toute son enfance le philosophe
et écrivain pascal bruckner a lui aussi
vu sa mère être violente et chaque jour
par son père
[Musique]
et
ce qui m'a aidé c'est de voir d'autres
gens
vivre différemment et ça ça a été pour
moi une révélation celle ci tient il ya
des familles harmonieux il ya des
familles ou où la mer
est plus importante que le père ou la
mère est plus forte que le père il ya
des familles où il ya une égalité entre
l'homme et la femme il ya des familles
on ne se dispute pas toute la journée où
les gens rient oui ça m'a aidé
sa chance fit également de partir en
pension très jeune et quand il revient à
la maison les fins de semaine c'est dans
sa tête qu'il s'évade
je me réfugie dans l'élite dans l'étude
dans les copains je m'évadais je pense
que c'est littérature qui m'a aidé le
fait d'écrire
il faut briser la malédiction
parce que c'est une malédiction
dans mon père a été son propre père pour
savoir ce qu'elle à l'origine de sa
violence y est il ya une violence votre
grand père s'appelle notre réseau mais
oui enfin 8 avril taper tout le monde
tente on sent que le yahia des ondes
héréditaire qui est qu'ils reviennent
mais bon si c'est difficile de tout
maîtriser
l'hystérie menthe et puis après j'ai dit
mais je suis d'un pur je les fais ça et
comme je vis avec une femme qui est
assez
qui est assez forte me dit arrête de
faire ton p1 et on verra ça me semble
qu'à ça me calme quoi qu'on porte en soi
comme bagage si on rencontre en face de
soi un être fort qui vous résistent
forcément vous ne pouvez pas vous
laisser aller
apprendre à se connaître bien s'entourer
sont sûrement des clés pour changer sa
route
malgré ses difficultés scolaires sephora
s'est inscrite en prépa cagnes
[Musique]
je pense personnellement je suis devenu
une fille sérieuse il ya de l'ambition
qui veut toujours
mettre fin ont des manques elle encore
j'arrive à avancer et par moments je
ressens j'ai l'impression d'être
heureuse
kenny n'avait plus d'amis
il vient d'en retrouver peu à peu il
laisse même éclaté de rire
bon point
[Musique]
toujours un peu perdu melia ne sait pas
trop ce qu'elle veut faire sinon quitter
la ville de saint quentin
[Musique]
papy bourdeilles
to you
luna fait ce soir ses 18 ans
loin de sa famille seul avec arthur son
petit ami
elle le connaît depuis quatre ans
il est devenu son rock
meba
[Musique]
j'espère que s'il ya des jeunes qui ont
vécu ça
c'est regarder puis
si on peut donner un coup de main on
locaux s'ils veulent eux je sais pas ça
se fasse entendre que
que ça serve pas rien plus haut
j'aimerais dire à tout le monde que et
surtout aux enfants aux enfants qui en
vivent aux enfants qui en ont vécu mais
qui arrive pas vraiment s'en sortir et
aux mamans qui qui n'osent pas partir
qu'il faut pas que vous ayez peur
il faut pas que vous ayez peur partait
je suis plus je défend plus les femmes
maintenant ses vaches u féministes ou
pas mais je défend plus les femmes quand
je regarde les infos ou dans les
journaux sur internet
aux patates il a tapé sur sa femme a tué
sa femme l'invasion même plus en plus de
trucs comme ça quels conseils leur
donner bah fuir oui je crois que c'est
le principal il faut partir
[Musique]